welcome back fast fit body sculpting the
sponsors of this next segment can help
you get rid of unwanted weight and
joining us to tell us more is the
founder doug zuko doug how are you
great good afternoon thank you for
joining us we have a lot of great
success stories to talk about who should
we start with
well let's talk let's let jamar speak
for himself
my name is michael jamar robinson i am
71 years old when i tell you one night i
was sitting up watching tv and i was
sitting at the front of my bed i was
crying because i was way overweight and
i thought why not try it i tried
everything else nothing worked
i made a call with fast to fast for 800
numbers the very next day this is what
fast fit did for me being short-winded
is no more it's completely gone
i feel like a feather when i'm walking
because this is what fast fit did for me
12 pounds took my body from being stand
like this
to like this
but you want to know how i look like
this i look like this because of fast
fit that's why i can be 71
and feel 30 because of fast
fit well that's got to be great to to
see those stories and i know we have a
few others to show but really quickly
let's just talk about what exactly you
guys do and who the ideal candidate is
for fast fit
absolutely well tomorrow was the ideal
candidate he had that belly that the
stubborn fatty couldn't get he couldn't
lose that visceral fat after losing 12
pounds of pure fat but it'd help his
confidence
but you know what we do the light
technology really helps the cellular
level while it helps naturally dispose
of fat
so
there's no pain no down time it's
absolutely fantastic for your health
as well as your looks
and you have a few other success stories
here that you wanted to highlight as
well we love seeing all of the before
and after so who else do we have
we have patricia patricia age 52 down 57
pounds of pure fat look at the
difference look at her skin quality how
young she looks
wow she looks amazing i mean it's
incredible to see all of these i mean
one after another all different types of
people types of bodies and it really
does work on everyone
it absolutely
does it
works for everybody because what we do
is focus on losing fat not necessarily
weight but losing fat and when you lose
fat your body rejuvenates and you look
amazing
and what type of technology do you guys
use and what kind of sets it apart from
other
services or similar treatments
we have a patent-pending fat loss system
it's light-based technology that not
only can help with subcutaneous fat but
also that stubborn belly fat visceral
fat which no other procedures can do so
it's all natural
lose fat just dispose of fat naturally
well doug thank you so much for always
jumping on here and showing us these
success stories and also for reminding
us that the procedure doesn't hurt and
the the end results are always worth it
so thank you so much for joining us fast
fit body sculpting has four locations
across the valley you can give them a
call at 1 800 fast fit there's a special
offer for the first 20 callers we will
be right back